nekem nagyon fontos volt és megerősítő
az hogy te mindig hallgatsz rám tehát
megtanultad az évek során hogy ez fontos
elmondtad te is hogy a te világodban ha
megkérdezi valaki hogy meg tudod-e
engedni a csapot akkor minthogyha
feltételeznéd hogy a másik olyan
inkompetens hog még eg csapot sem tud
megengedni én erre sose gondoltam hogy
így is lehet erre a kérdésre gondolni
egy nőt megismerni nem olyan mint egy
festmény amit nézel utána megtanulod ha
sokat nézted és már a végén minden ecset
van ás a a szemedbe ég beleég az agyadba
a teljes kép tehát egy nő nem
[Zene]
ilyen sziasztok egy számomra nagyon
különleges epizód következik ugyanis a
feleségemmel ültem lebeszélgetni a
házasság hete kért fel minket hogy
készítsünk egy saját podcastet amikor
arról beszélgetünk hogy mitől is szent
egy házasság mi az amit az elmúlt 10-13
évben megtapasztaltunk milyen
alapelveket fogalmaz meg magunknak és mi
az ami a házasságunkat ebben az
időszakban megtartotta tartsatok velünk
a következő epizódban mindenféle
izgalmas dolgokról fogunk beszélgetni az
az igazság hogy izgultam én is és izgult
a feleségem is milyen lesz ennyire
személyes dolgokról beszélgetni de
szerintem nagyon jól sikerült úgyhogy jó
szórakozást kívánok
üdvözlök minden kedves hallgatót ma is
egy különleges epizóddal jelentkezek
ugyanis a vendégem az nem más mint az én
kedves feleségem üdvözöllek téged a mű
sorba sziasztok szia egy kicsit izgulok
a az igazság én is mert ez egy szokatlan
felállás számunkra viszont mivel a téma
maga annyira fontos ugyanis a
házasságról fogunk beszélgetni ezért úgy
döntöttünk hogy mégis bevállaljuk és egy
kicsit belemélyedünk azokba a kérdésekbe
hogy mitől is működik a mi házasságunk
ugyanis az elmúlt 10 évben tehát 10 éve
vagyunk házasok de valójában 13 éve
ismerjük egymást ezt hogyha megnézzük
hogy most 37 éves vagyok azt jelenti az
életünk egyhmadát már együtt eltöltöttük
sőt hogyha a felnőtt éveinket nézzük
akkor akkor több mint felét vagy több
mint kéthmadát eltöltöttük egymással és
ez e ez tényleg egy nagy befektetés volt
és sok mindent megtanultunk egymásról
három gyermeket vállaltunk és azt tudom
mondani hogy szerintem egynél megálltunk
volna hogyha nem értjük meg azokat a
dolgokat amiket megértettünk a
házassággal kapcsolatban úgyhogy a
házasság hete mivel hamarosan jön ők
felkértek minket arra hogy hogy kicsit
beszélgessünk magukról a azokról az
alapelvekről amiket megtapasztaltunk a
házasságba és és ezért gondoltuk hogy
akkor leülünk és és végigvesszük ezeket
a a az alapelveket amiket így
megfogalmaztunk
magunknak az is hozzátartozik magához a
az epizódhoz hogy ezelőtt két évvel az
egyik közös
ismerősünk beszélt veled és és mondta
hogy problémák vannak a ház ágába
kommunikációs problémák és megkérdezted
hogy segítene-e neki hogyha írnánk pár
kérdést pár témát felvetnénk ami ami
segít majd nekik így
praktikusan elindítani egy-egy témát és
akkor nagy lelkesen nekiálltunk és pár
nap alatt az összeállítottuk azt hiszem
vagy 20 kérdés pontosan és utána
részletesen kidolgoztuk és a képeket
szerkesztettünk hozzá és ilyen kicsi
kártyák formájában egy ilyen játék
formájában próbáltunk ö készülni
kedveskedni az ironikus az hogy aztán
nem is igényelték ezt a kártyát később
tehát hogy hogy megmaradt nekünk é s
mind gondolkoztam rajta ezt hol fogjuk
felhasználni ugyanis ez is egy ilyen
valamilyen alapelv hogy azt látom hogy
minden amit így teljes szívből csinálunk
előbb-utóbb valahol visszaköszön úgyhogy
arra gondoltam hogy ennek a podcastnek a
struktúrája lehetne az hogy egy pár
kérdést amit így kiszemelgettün
magunknak átbeszélünk hogy ez a mi hogy
hogyan jelenik meg a mi házasságunkban
remélem hogy
hogy izgalmas lesz a hallgatók számára
is és a podcast címének azt szeretném
adni hogy miért is szent a házasság és
ez egy fontos kérdés
mert mert beszélnünk kell arról mit
jelent az hogy szent és hogy hogy a
házasságot miért tartjuk mi is szentnek
és akkor utána tudunk majd belemélyedni
hogy hogyan is éljük ezt meg így a nap
mint nap úgyhogy ezt gondoltam hogy
röviden összefoglalom és akkor utána
aztán elkezdünk beszélgetni a
kérdésekről ha valamilyen történet
eszedbe jut vagy valamilyen gondolat van
bármikor szakíts meg és és majd
hozzáfűzheted és akkor vágjunk is bele a
házasságot a katolikus egyház szentnek
tartja és fellapoztam így a a kekket
hogy hogy miért is mit is jelent az hogy
szent a katekizmust a katekizmust igen
katolikus egyház
katekizmusát és
ott ott bizonyos s pontból egy elég
általános definíciót kaptam hogy minden
ami istenhez tartozik a szent de hogy
egy kicsit jobban bele akartam menni
abba hogy hogy mit is jelent számomra a
szent hogy miért mert igazából az hogy
ha ha ha egy ilyen általános definíciót
adok az nem adja meg számomra a súlyját
hogy miért is kell komolyan venni a
házasságot viszont
hogyha
ha mélyebben megértjük akkor tehát én
egy praktikus személy vagyok bizonyos
szempontból fontos hogy ahhoz hog
érzelmileg bele tudjak kapcsolódni
megértsem mé vagy bocsánat elméleti
mélyebben megértsem hogy miért miért
szent a házasság és jordan petersonnak
volt egy gondolata amit pár évvel
ezelőtt mondott és és nagyon megragadta
a figyelmemet ez az ószövetségben a van
egy ilyen történet amikor dávid a
szentek szentjét egyik helyről a másikra
viszi el és egy szekérre felrakva egy
azt hiszem hogy egy
pataknál megdől a megbillen a szekér és
szinte leesik és
isten parancsba adta hogy a frigyláda az
szent ahhoz nem szabad
hozzányúlni úgyhogy amikor látta a
szolga hogy dőlle a szekérről akkor
odament a szekérhez és és megpróbálta
megtartani
viszont isten haragjával sújtotta és és
meghalt na most ez egy nagyon furcsa
történet és első hangzásra ez egy
igazságtalan dolog hát jó dolgot akar
tehát hogy hogy most
egészeren nem nem tarthatja meg hogy ne
dőljön le a a fritty ládáát a föld az az
az az
mocskos és bizonyos szempontból
minthogyha azt mondaná isten hogy lehet
hogy a föld mocskos de az emberi kéz az
még mocskosabb mint a föld nem nyúlhat
hozzá valaki anélkül hogy avatatlan
legyen még a jó indulat sem elegendő
ahhoz hogy valaki csak úgy
hozzányúlhasson a szent dolgokhoz és ez
úgy megragad bennem hogy ha jó
indulattal is de hogyha hozzányúlunk a
szent dolgokhoz akkor annak a
következménye halál ezt peterson mondta
amúgy és egyet is értek ezzel a
katolikus egyház a házasság intézményét
szentnek tartja vagyis azt jelenti hogy
akármilyen jó indulattal is nyúlnánk
hozzá magához a házasság intézményéhez
akkor is a következménye halál ez mit
jelent én számomra ez most azt jelenti
hogy az elmúlt évtizedekben európa és a
nyugati világ folyamatosan játszott a
házasság gondolatával hogy hol lehetne
egy picit torzítani hogy minél inkább
befogadóbb legyen hogy minél hogy hogy
hogy hogy ne csak férfi és nő között
legyen házasság és hogy hogy konkrétan
mit is ismerünk el házasságnak és hogy
hogy állatokkal lehet-e házasodni
például és
ahogy ha elkezdünk játszani a szent
dolgokkal akkor a következménye halál ez
például megjelenik a szaporulati
indexben hogy hogy a nyugati világ
szaporulati indexe az az önfenntartás
alatt van lassan elpusztul a nyugati
világ ez ilyen szempontból is megjelenik
de megjelenik
a hétköznapokban is amikor valaki
valaki életellenesen kezdi élni az
életét önmagát pusztítva olyan
kapcsolatokba belelépve ahol inkább
degerenálódik a a személyiség mint az
hogy fejlődjön
úgyhogy ezt így megértve az elmúlt
években én is azt látom hogy házasság
valóban szent hogy nekem is a feladatom
az hogy alázatosan megértsem hogy miért
szent hogy hogy alávessem magam és
megértsem átalakuljak és átadjam magam a
házasságnak a a mi házasságunknak
úgyhogy ez lenne maga az elméleti
megalapozás számomra hogy miért is szent
a házasság amúgy zárójelben az anyaság
is számomra egy szent tehát az amikor a
a katolikus egyházba szent képnek
tartjuk amikor szűz mária tartja a kis
jézust ez valóban egy szent kép mert az
a társadalom amelyik elkezdi nem
szentként tisztelni ezt a képet
valójában az anyaság intézményé vagy az
anyaságot mint mint kapcsolatot a
gyermekkel degenerálja és nyilván hogy a
nők akkor azt mondják hogy köszönjük
szépen de nincs ked ün szülni hármat
mert a testünk eldeformálódik mert a mka
kiszolgáltatottá válunk kiszolgáltatottá
válunk a munkaerőpiacról lemaradunk
igazából alig tudunk érvet mondani csak
egyedül az egyedüli érv amit tudunk
mondani az az hogy ez egy szent dolog
belevetjük magunkat anélkül hogy hogy
értenénk teljesen és majd utólag persze
értelmet nyer tehát hogy erről is majd
beszélhetünk hogy utólag hogyan látjuk
most így a a gyermekeinket de azért
azért szükséges volt az az elhatározás
hogy nem tudjuk hogy mit csinál de de
valamiért az elődeink és az elődeink sok
generációval visszamenleg úgy gondolták
hogy a házasság és a gyermekvállalás az
egy
szent küldetés most a rajt tamulnait
leállítanám a beszélgetést és
megkérnélek hogy ezt még ismételd el úgy
három-négy kontextusában ezt a az
anyaság fontossága női szerep s ezt az
egészet mert nagyon szeretem
hallgatni és nagyon sokat jelentett
amikor pont a akkor hallottad ezt a
gondolatot amikor gyereknevelésén otthon
voltam és azt éreztem hogy a a
társadalom peremére
kerültem a kapcsolataim is már két éve
voltam gyereknevelésén és a kapcsolataim
is rájöttem hogy ha én nem hívok fel
valakit akkor nem fognak engem felhívni
nem fognak
megkeresni tehát nagyon lemaradoztak
és nagyon sokat jelented hogy elkezdted
mondani nekem hogy mennyire fontos ez a
szerep ez a feladat hogy ez egy küldetés
hogy hogy bár a társadalom nem
hangsúlyozza kellőképpen biztos vannak
olyan területek ahol beszélnek erről az
emberek de mintogyha nem is beszélnének
hanem természetes hogy a nő gyerekeket
szül de hogy eközben ő otthon hogyan
érzi magát és hogy ezt a oké k kaptunk
gyereknevelési pén
de valahogy a
kompetenciánkkat nem nem nem is tudom a
tehetségünket a tehát te egy építész
vagy ak kreatív oldaladat nem nagyon
tudtad kiélni na ez hogy a szakmámba
közben ugye visszavonultam már kérdezték
hogy mikor megyek vissza miért nem
haladok miért nem
fejlődök miközben éreztem hogy helyes
amit csinálok de mégis tehát volt ez a
kettősség úy nagyon szeretem ezt
hallgatni akkor egy kicsit meg
beszéljünk erről mert a hallgatók
kedvéért három gyermekünk van összesen
hét évet ültél otthon a a három
gyermekkel ez ez nagyon hosszú idő mert
valójában ezalatt nőttünk egymáshoz
közelebb ezalatt a hét év alatt és
átformálódtunk mind a ketten a
személyiségünk a hét év
alatt a gyerekek három évig jártak
óvodába három évig mindenkivel három
évet töltöttél valójában és ez ez ez
ilyen tehát három évesen mentek óvodába
három évesen mentek óvodába pontosabban
és a sokszor kaptál egy olyan kritikát
ilyen burkoltan hogy amikor már egy éves
volt akkor én már elmentem dolgozni és
ez ez így belső feszültségként
folyamatosan őröl téged hogy akkor miért
is vállaljunk gyermeket erre a a világra
hogy ha ha ennyire kell hajtani a munkát
ennyire kell pénzt keresni meg
egyáltalán ennyire szörnyű a világ tehát
ez a másik oldalról hogy hogy a a
híreket a fel különösen a te
facebookodon hogyha a híreket így fel
lapozzuk akkor mert csak hírek vannak a
facebookon mer mert csak és csak
negatívak hogy
hogy ha ennyire szörnyű a világ hogy
ennyi baleset történik és ennyi
gonoszság benne akkor akkor miért
szüljünk gyermeket a világra vagy miért
szülj gyermeket erre a világra e ezeket
nem lehet csak felületesen megválaszolni
tehát a felületes válasz itt nem
elegendő és ezért kellett mélyebbre
menjünk és emlékszem az egyik gondolat
az egy ez egy ez egy újító gondolat volt
amikor amikor számomra is új volt
jonathan peugeottól értettem meg hogy a
feminin és a maszkulin miben különbözik
és egy gondolatot elmondok a feminin az
amelyik rejtett és a maszkulin az
amelyik látható és amikor erre rájöttünk
hogy ez szimbolikailag is így van tehát
a a bibliában is végigvonul de mindenhol
megjelenik ez hogy a femininot egy
rejtett egy misztikus köd körbevonja és
és nem lehet ezért bizonyos szempontból
színről színre látni olyan mint a
szentlélek nem lehet tudni hogy hol fúj
viszont ez pont beleillett abba a a
szerepbe amit te
ami te benne voltál hogy valójában el
voltál rejtve a világ elől de mégis
bizonyos szempontból a háttérben
hatalmas erőd volt tehát ez a másik
mondata a nem lehet tudni hogy mi
történt az éjszaka de reggel mikor a
király felébredt akkor meggondolta magát
tehát ilyen a feminin ilyen a feminin
hogy a háttérben alakítja és és mozgatja
a szálakat és ez ez ez egy méltóságot
adott neked hogy hogy a szerepedben vagy
benne egy feminin szerepben vagy benne
hogy a háttérből tényleg alakítassz
engem is és alakítod a világot is igen
de amit itt közbeszúrnék mivel hogy
megengedted hogy igen igen közb szóljak
az az
hogy fontos hogy a feminin elmondja azt
hogy mit lát mit érez mert sokszor olyan
kapcsolati szálakat
olyan személyiség vonásokat látok meg a
körülötted mozgó személyekben amiket te
nem és olyan ötleteim jönnek amik neked
nem jönnek és ezzel tényleg jól
kiegészítelek viszont nekem nagyon
fontos volt és megerősítő az hogy te
mindig hallgatsz rám tehát megtanultad
az évek során hogy ez fontos
üüm fontos és hallgatsz rám és ettől
ettől jobban szeretsz jobban elismersz
jobban a helyemre helyezel és ettől én
se kell annyira agresszívan vagy
manipulatív
módon kifejezzem azokat a nem hogy
akaratomat de meglátásomat vag
intuíciómat igen inó igen errő erről
most később lesz szó részletesebben bele
akarok menni de tényleg az van hogy a
feminin az amelyik észreveszi a
potenciált a maszkulin az amelyik
betölti ezt a potenciált tehát hogy az
van a feminin az egy űrt hoz létre egy
kérdést tesz fel a maszkulin pedig
betölti ezt az űrt és válaszol erre a
kérdésre és ez ez a dinamika nagyon
érvényes kettőnk között ugyanis tényleg
folyamatosan észreveszel dolgokat sokkal
érzékenyebb vagy mint én viszont nekem
segítenem kell ezt megfogalmazni hogy
mit is vettél pontosan észre és akkor
már az a a megfogalmazás az már egy fél
válasz tehát úy ahogy ádám az amelyik
nevet ad az állatoknak úgy úgy nekem az
én feladatom az hogy verbálisan
megfogalmazzak dolgokat segítsek és
valójában ez egy érdekes játék kettőnk
között mert dave rsey mesélte el nagyon
viccesen de amúgy érvényes ez a mi
kapcsolatunkban is hogy a feleségét
mindig elviszi a tárgyalásokra és mert
mert rájött arra hogy a hánzor nem
hallgatott a feleségére minimum 10000
dollárjába került vagy vagy vagy még
többe és és ez tényleg így van tehát
annyira érdekes dolgokat vettél észre
akár a biznisvilágba akár akár a családi
vonatkozásokban a gyerekekben levő
potenciálban hogy hogy hogy hát nem is
tudták azok a vacsoránál ülők hogy az a
nénike aki ott csendbennek a felesége
vá eszi
igen ilyen a hogy szürcsöli a spagettit
hogy
igen nekik kell megfeleljenek vagy nekik
kellett volna
igen igen úgyhogy én azt mondom hogy
kezdjük el a beszélgetést hozzunk pár
praktikus gondolatot azzal kapcsolatban
hogy hogyan is működik a mi mi
házasságunk és és valahova eljutunk
igazából annyi gondolat feljött már most
bennem hogy szerintem ha kérdések nélkül
folytatnánk tovább is a másfél órát
betöltenénk
de hoztuk ezt a 20 kérdést a 20
kérdésből most nyilván lesz egy t fel
810-re ö alkalmunk hogy róla
beszélgessünk de egy izelítőt szeretnék
adni és a a hallgatók számára majd ezt
egy egy pdf formájában a megtaláljátok a
videó alatt teljesen publikus
használjátok ezt a kártyát
beszélgessetek adjatok visszajelzést
ezekről én azt is el tudom képzelnié
később egy egy igazi kártyajáték legyen
ami belőle amit majd lehet kapni az
áruházakban de az első ízelítő kérdés az
pont a kiemelkedian eredményes emberek
hétszokásából az egyik alapgondolat hogy
ahhoz hogy megértsünk valakit
igazán ahhoz figyelnünk kell és ahhoz
hogy megértessük magunkat először meg
kell értsük a másik személyt tehát
amikor van egy vitás helyzet akkor több
lehetőség is van hogy hogyan lehet
hozzáállni a vitához és a legstupitabb
módja annak hogy hogyan álljunk hozzá az
az hogy hogy elmondjuk hogy mi mire
gondoltunk és utána amikor a másik
személy próbálja az ő álláspontját
képviselni akkor mi nem is figyelünk
hanem csak várjuk hogy befejezze és vagy
ab vagy ennél még rosszabb beleszólunk
abba amit ő mondott és és nem vagyunk
hajlandóak figyelemben venni a másik
személyt és ezt gyakor nagyon gyakran
megismétlődik a férfiaknál férfiak
intellektuálisabb beállítottságúak és
azt hiszik hogy ha én problémegoldóak és
problémamegoldóak ha én most megoldom a
problémát és intellektuálisan leér velem
a a a feleségemet akkor minden meg van
oldva nincs semmi megoldva ha tényleg
annyira stupidak a férfiak hogy arra
gondolnak hogy ha le is győztem
intellektuálisan nem egy legyőzött
keserű valaki lesz mellettem aki az első
alkalmat meg fogja ragadni hogy most a a
késtbeli szúrja a a a a persze
metaforikusan a a a a férjébe hogy
valahol visszaadja azt a sértést és azt
a bántást azt a azt az elutasítottságot
amit azáltal érzett hogy hogy leérvelte
a férfi igen úgyhogy úgyhogy ez nem
működik és és nem lehet nem lehet
legyőzni a nőket nem nem nem nem így
működik nem nem háború ez az egész hanem
egy ez két férfi között működik egy két
férfi között működik tehát a
bizniszvilágban működik az hogy
intellektuálisan még még szinte még ott
se tehát hogy gyakorlatilag tudunk
hieria van ott hierarchia van és tudunk
beszélgetni de viszont amikor egy ilyen
szintre zsugorodik a beszélgetés hogy
csak intellektuális érvek mennek
egymással szembe és nincs meg az
alapvető bizalom és nincs meg az
alapvető megértés akkor egyszerűen
egymás mellett elmegy a két ér tehát még
a gyakorlatilag a férfiak között is az
van hogy először a másikat kell
megértsük és utána értessük meg magunkat
na most itt elmesélnék egy példát a
hallgatóknak kíváncsi vagyok hogy hogy
te ezt hogyan élted meg a
szavak mást jelentenek nekem és mást
jelentenek neked és a a amikor amikor
frissen házasodtunk össze akkor pláne
két külön világból érkeztünk az én
világomban ha valamire valamit kérek
valakitől akkor egyszerűen elmondom hogy
hogy ezt hozd ide ha kedves akarok lenni
akkor azt mondom hogy ezt kérlek hozd
ide ha még kedvesebb akarok lenni akkor
azt mondom hogy esetleg ezt ide tudnád
hozni vagy hogyha még kedvesebb ha nem
probléma esetleg ide tudnád kk ezt tehát
hog minél több szó van benne annál
kedvesebb és emlékszem hogy kolozsváron
éppen szereltem a csapot és úgy be
voltam feküdve a a a a a csapalá és ott
csöpögött minden és akkor azért hogy ne
kelljen onnan még kimásszak megkértem
hogy esetleg meg tudnád kérlek engedni
azt a csapot hogy lássam hogy folyik-e
és erre azt mondod meg tudnám és erre
kiviharoztál hát mondom uram teremtőm
egy harpiával
összeházasodtál hogy hogy hogy alig telt
el pár hónap és máris váláson kell
gondolkozzak hogy te jó ég hogy ebből mi
lesz hogy na és akkor ott egy ideig
füstölögtem valahogy összeszedtem magam
és akkor elkezdtünk róla beszélgetni én
én biztos voltam benne hogy a probléma
csak veled lehet tehát hogy most egy
ilyen gyönyörűen szépen megfogalmazott
kedves mondat után egy ilyen csúnya
választ kapjak ez ez ez számomra ez
100%-ig biztos voltam benne hogy hogy
hogy most veled van a baj viszont ahogy
kezdtünk beszélgetni egy nagyon érdekes
dolog történt
elmondtad te is hogy a te világodban ha
megkérdezi valaki hogy meg tudod-e
engedni a csapot akkor minthogyha
feltételeznéd hogy a másik olyan
inkompetens hogy még eg csapot sem tud
megengedni én erre sose gondoltam hogy
így is lehet erre a kérdésre gondolni és
ez egy egy nagyon szép és szerintem
vissza fog köszönni majd egy későbbi
témánál is hogy ez egy nagyon szép példa
olyan szempontból
hogy amiután megbeszéltük a méregfogát
kihúztuk ennek a kérdésnek és utána
sokszor megismételtem még hogy fel
tudnád gyújtani a villanyt vagy ezt meg
tudnád csinálni vagy és és miután
kimondtam azért próbáltad leszokni de
miután kimondtam utána abban a
pillanatban már tudtam hogy kérlek
szépen hogy hogy hogy hogy hogy rosszul
fogalmaztam és egymásra néztünk és már
egyet kacagtunk rajta és kihúztuk a
méregfogát ennek és valójában igazi
vitánk sosem volt emiatt volt más miatt
de de emiatt nem volt úgyhogy ez egy
szép példa arra hogy hogyan lehet
egymást megérteni és valójában pontosan
úgy értettelek meg hogy először te
megértetted magad meg akartam érteni
hogy te miért mérgelődtél fel és miután
megértettem után próbáltam elmondani az
én oldalam és és amúgy ezt praktikusan
is lehet így használni még egy utolsó
gondolatot
hogy ezt a úgy nevezi a a a a stevenh
cavy hogy hogy a beszélőbot technikája
hogy mintogyha képzelné mint az
indiánoknak a beszélőbotja hogy az
indiánoknak a a sátrában történt az hogy
amikor valakinek a kezében ott volt a
bot akkor csak az a személy beszélhetett
és addig beszélt ameddig úgy nem érezte
hogy mindenki meg nem értette és csak
akkor adta tovább a botot amikor biztos
volt benne hogy hogy mindenkivel
összhangban van de ha tovább adta a
botot akkor már csak az a személy
beszélhet akinél a a bot van most
jelenleg és és mindenki figyel úgyhogy
ezt így fejben lehet alkalmazni
mintogyha elképzelnénk minthogyha
valamelyikünknél ott van a bot és aki
éppen beszél akkor azt a személyt meg
kell hallgatni és esetleg meg kell kérni
a másikat hogy tegyük fel hogyha most én
beszélek akkor meg kell kérjelek téged
arra hogy kérlek foglald össze azt amit
most mondtam és hogyha jól össze tudod
foglalni úgyhogy én már semmit sem tudok
hozzátenni akkor azt jelenti hogy
megértettél és akkor átadhatom viszont
ha átadtam akkor akkor figyelnem kell és
én kell megismételjem azt amit te
mondasz
úgyhogy valami jut-e eszedbe ezzel a
történettel kapcsolatban ami amit így
megemlítenél hát legelőször is azt
mondanám el hogy amikor a kártyákat mi
elkészítettük
akkor ezek a mi kincseink azok a
gondolatok amiket behoztál a
kapcsolatunkba amiket együtt gyakorlatba
ültettünk és úgy éreztük hogy has ált
igazából nekünk is jó volt hogy leírtuk
ezeket persze szívesen megosszuk
másokkal azért is írtuk le mi is
tanultuk de hogy ezek ilyen apró
mérföldkövek a házasságunkban ami
erősségünk mint pár házaspár az az hogy
ezeket meg tudjuk fogalmazni
üüm amit hozzátennék ehhez a történethez
az az
hogy nagyon nagy különbség van a férfi
és a nő között a gondolkodásában erről
már biztos a hallgatók is olvastak me
hallottak hogy a a a férfiak képesek
arra hogy például ha több konfliktus van
egyszerre a házaspár között akkor a
férfi képes arra hogy félretegye betegye
egy dobozba vagy a problémákat amik
vannak becsomagolja beleteszi egy
dobozba és beteszi egy fiókba vagy é nem
fonak ös aé nem fojnak össze minden
külön sterilen elválasztva egy egy doboz
van és amikor egyedül van akkor szépen
kezdi kinyitja a doboz rendet rak arrébb
teszi veszi a következőt és valahogy egy
ilyen csapszerelés számára egy doboz
amit meg kell csinálni és ha mondjuk
lenne
konfliktusunk a háttérbe akkor nem
kapcsolná össze a kettőt hogy talán
azért reagálok hirtelen vagy ha
valamilyen személyes problémám van akkor
talán azért reagál tehát ő konkrétan
most csapot szerel tehát ezért van az
hogyha ki van téve egy tál kimosott vagy
szennyes ruha és be kell tenni a
mosógépbe és mondjuk az út közepére van
kitéve akkor a férfi ezt úgy értelmezi
hogy ez egy akadály amit át kell lépni
szóval eszébe se jut hogy ezt meg kéne
fogni és be kéne tenni a mosógépbe és
elindítani erre van az a történet hogy
igen már bungor mondta hogy egyszer egy
nő odajött hozzá és mondta hogy atyám a
férfiak nem látják a szenny
eseket nos eközben pedig a nőknek minden
össze van kuszálódva minden egyszerre
történik és a béke akkor áll be hogyha
az összes szálon kialakul a béke
elcsitulnak a konfliktusok és
rendeződnek most nálam ez úgy érzem egy
kicsit még komplexebb
mert mivel a családomból hozom azt
hogy nem is tudom hogy fogalmazzam meg
van bennem egy ilyen radikalitás arra
hogy legyen konfliktus legyen konfliktus
mert amikor a konfliktus meg van oldva
akkor utána olyan szép az egig béke az
egy igazi béke amíg nincs konfliktus
csak a felszínen érzed hogy most úgy
elmegy de a háttérbe érzed hogy van
valami az mindig kibukhat kijöhet mint a
szőnyegen hogy egyet így arrébb nyomod
azt a púpot s akkor egyet arrébb megy de
az egyszer a szőnyeg végén csak kiborul
szóval hogy bennem van egy ilyen
késztetés hogy szembemenjek a a
konfliktussal és vállaljam és emiatt is
van az hogy ha valamit nem értek vagy
valami bosszant akkor azt el fogom
mondani erre számíthatsz és igazából azt
vettük észre hogy a 10 éves hát igazából
13 éves távlatban ez már gyümölcsöző
tehát rengeteg konfliktusunk volt főleg
a kapcsolatunk elején tehát az
együttjárás ismerkedés folyamatában is
hosszú négy órás
fárasztó csontörőáó
fárasztó viták veszekedések dühősen amíg
megtanultunk konfrontálódni megtanultuk
megérteni egymást és talán még ezt
tenném hozzá ehhez a gondolathoz hogy
főleg a a házasságkötésünk utáni
időszakban gyakran éreztem azt hogy nem
értesz meg és a viták is valahogy úgy
izomból lettek megoldva úgy
stratégikusan minthogyha a szavak
sorrendjét kellett megbeszéljük vy ami
nagyon tetszett az az hogy minden
vitának volt egy konklúziója volt egy
soha nem ért véget egy három- néy órás
vita úgy hogy nem vontunk le egy
következtetést egy építő dolgot amit
legközelebb csak egy hajszálnyi tudtunk
megfogalmazni az egészet képtelenek
voltunk öszb látni de azt a
hajszálnyi konklúziót levonjuk és
akkor valami amit te is teszel és én is
teszek és jobb lesz hüüm és ahogy ezt az
évek alatt gyakoroltuk egyre inkább
bennem is nőtt a bizalom és a megértés
azt hiszem hogy azt hiszem ez a
legnagyobb aján áka a konfliktusainknak
é a tehát a 13 év alatt az első három
évben rengeteget vitatkoztunk és akkor
rengeteg kétej volt bennem és gyanítom
benned is hogy vajon érdemes-e
összeházasodjunk hogyha ennyi vitánk van
lesz-e ez jobb vagy összekötjük az
életünket és és megőrülünk
igen és és a a házasságunk első éve is
elég intenzív volt és miután sára
megszületett még egy kábé fél év volt
amelyik nagyon-nagyon intenzív volt és
akkor utána kezdett minden megfordulni
tehát most nem vitatkozunk az elmúlt
öt-h év elég csendes volt ilyen
szempontból ha vitáink voltak ritkán
voltak és már nem belső dolgok miatt
feltétlenül hanem hanem külső dolgok
miatt tehát hogy egyre egyre számomra
egyre nyugottabb ez a házasság de nem
naív nyugalom van benne nem hamis
nyugalom van benne hanem hanem igazi
nyugalomy bizonság iz ez egy erőforrás
nekünk nekem is igen itt akkor akkor egy
másik alapelvet megemlítené ami számomra
fontos hogy miért is szent a házasság
tehát maga az az eskü amit kimondunk
hogy holtomiglan holtodiglan ez
egy a egy naiv felfogásban ez egy
ilyenkor a a elképzelek ilyen két barbit
aki egy ilyen rózsaszín naplementében
egymás k vagy két barb bocsánat egy
barbit és egy ken n babát
elnézést és és egy ilyen rózsaszín
naplementében egymás kezét fogják ott
vannak a a hullámok előtt és minden
békés és valami ilyen kép alakult ki
gyermekként a
ebbe a holtomiglan holtodiglanba és
ennél
sokkal brutálisabb és és és és
hétköznapi és praktikusabb ez a ez a
mondat számomra most már azzá vált tehát
nem nem ez a
rózsaszín nyálas amerikai kép jut
eszembe erről hanem másik oldaló azt is
jelenti hogy akármennyire őrülten is
fogsz viselkedni nem foglak elhagyni ezt
jelenti a holtomignal holtodignal és
hogyha ezt halál komolyan gondolom
hogyha
nem tudsz semmi olyant tenni hogy én itt
elhagyjalak ez az a pont amikor
elkezdhetsz őszinte lenni vagy fordítva
mert ameddig ott van a két tej és egy
párkapcsolatban hogy hogy ha elég
őszinte vagyok hogy ha igazán elmondom a
gondolataimat lehet hogy itt fogsz
hagyni akkor akkor nem fogok őszinte
lenni viszont hogyha azt látom hogy ezt
a problémát vagy megoldjuk vagy
megőrülünk tehát nincs kiút ebből tehát
az eskü kötelez akkor akkor meg kell
oldjuk és és akkor akkor ez a krízis
kell ahhoz hogy hogy hogy az legmélyebb
legfájobb dolgokhoz is belemenjünk és és
és meg megpróbáljuk megoldani mert
ameddig nincs ez a krízis ameddig mindig
van egy menekülő úton addig addig
álltatjuk magunkat védi az egónk a a
személyünket hogy ne kelljen változzunk
és az az az a személy aki ezt nem
gondolja komolyan aki ezt az esküt úgy
mondja ki hogy felületesen lehet nem is
volt házas soha lehet hogy formálisan
azt mondták hogy házasok de a házasság
akkor kezdődik amikor halál komolyan
gondolja két fél azt hogy holtomiglan
holtodiglan nem fogsz tudni semmit tenni
hogy én itt hagyjalak és és ez ez
tényleg a következő 50-60 évre
szól azt hiszem hogy ez az a pont
amikor elmesélhetjük azt hogy mekkora
ajándék volt nekünk
a az első gyerekünk
után jövő gyermekágyi depresszió
mert ez volt az a pont amikor teljes
mértékben kicsúszott a talaj alólam
mindaz a magas önbecsülés ami egészen
addig kísért meg az a
stabilitás teljesen mintha kihúzták
volna a szőnyeget alólam és ez volt az a
pont amikor mélységet adott ezeknek a
mondatoknak amiket elmondtál
mert valóban voltak olyan kitöréseim
amik ilyen hisztérikus és ilyen őrültnek
tűnő értelmetlen
és nehéz pillanatok és ez volt az amikor
maximálisan azt éreztem hogy nem értesz
meg és egyedül vagyok mindazokkal a
terhekkel
felelősségekkel amit akkor az élet abban
a helyzetben kimért rá
és ezt elmesélném hogy mennyire nehéz
helyzetben voltunk tehát amikor
kolozsváron laktunk akkor egy negyedik
emeleti lakást kaptunk ami a legfelsőbb
emellet volt és a nyarak hihetetlenül
melegek
voltak le kellett a redőnyöket húzni
azért hogy ne melegedjen fel a lakás
annyira és két fiatal szülő aki aki még
most tanulja hogy mit kezdjen egy
babával aki sír egy lesötétített lakásba
és ráadás sajnos annyira
tapasztalatlanok voltunk hogy k
írt le h mik lehetn az amiér a gyermek
sír keztük minden alkalommal pipálni hy
von melyik melyikre ha reagálunk akkor
reagál a gyerek és és és néha egyszerűen
nem volt megoldás tehát hogy egyszerűen
akkor is sírt hogyha mind a kilenc
pontot kipipáltuk és egy lesötétett
lakásba amikor amikor ki se tudtunk
menni és azt a tanácsot kaptuk amúgy és
ezt ajánlom mindenkinek a figyelmébe
hogy ne hallgassa meg hogy az első hat
hétben ne mozduljon ki az anyuka
egyáltalán a gyermekkel hogy nehogy
valamilyen betegséget elkapjon lehet de
közben megőrül közben a nő tehát hogy
hogy hogy egy pár négyzetméteren leélni
az életed úgy hogy le van sötétítve a
lakás és sír egy gyermek amikor azt sem
tudod hogy már ki vagy és hirtelen a
tested változott és a státusod változott
a hangulatod ingadozik egy gyermekágyi
depresszió és én közben kellett menjek
dolgozni
ez ez eg ez egy nagyon nehéz időszak
volt igen de ez volt az a mélység amikor
odakerültél hogy mindaz amit ha olvastál
eddig nagyon vérkomoly lett tehát ott ot
el kellett döntsed hogy vagy külső
segítséget kérsz és lelécelsz és úgy
teszel hogy hát nem én voltam a hibás
hüüm vag vagy intellektuálisan
megmagyarázom hogy miér intellektuálisan
megmagyarázott hogy egy igazi nőnek
miért a otthon a helye a gyermekkel
például és
elmész
de ez volt az a pont ahol én én ezt így
fogalmaznám hogy lehajoltál hozzá mert
akkor én nagyon lent
voltam és felemeltél és elkezd t keresni
hogy hogyan érthetnél meg hogyan hogyan
lehetne jobb és azok a stratégiák amiket
ott hoztál az én életemben hogy akkor
legyenek kimenőim x naponta egyedül hogy
kezdjünk el randizni legyen minden
napnak egy öröme és azt az írjuk össze
hogy mik azok a dolgok amik nekem örömet
okoznak kezdjünk el randizni
rendszeresen heti szinten vagy hetente
többször ketten mozduljunk ki és és
töltsünk együtt időt mint a gyerekek
előtt hogy érezzük azt a párkapcsolati
hangulatot
meg volt még egy egyességünk emlékszel
hogy azt mondtad hogy ha kétszer
felhívsz telefonon bármelyik tárgyalás
kellős közepén felveszem a telefont és
hogyha arra készül hazamenjek akármi van
hazöök na na ez ez nagyon jó hogy
elmondtad mert ez nagyon sokszor éreztem
hogy a munka tehát ha féltékeny lehetnék
ebbe a 10 évbe akkor nagyon sokszor a
telefonodra vagy a munkahelyedre voltam
féltékeny és nem azért mert nekem nem
ilyen a
munkahelyem hanem azért mert elrabolt
tőlem mert azt éreztem hogy fontosabb és
valahányszor azt kértem hogy most maradj
itt vagy gyere haza vagy most segíts
megoldani
akkor mindig megtaláltad az útját hogy
prioritizálj engem és ez is szerintem
segített abb hogy fontosnak érezzem
magam se ebbe az anyaság hogy
visszatérjünk erre a
feminitásra hogy a feminitásomban hogy
az én nőességemben növekedjek hogy
helyesnek érezzem azt hogy én tehát
lejárt a hét év de a hét év után hogy
nem visszaálltam egy nyolc órás munkába
hanem azt tudtam eldönteni hogy
félmunkaidőbe kezdek valamit a
szakmámmal és indítok egy vállalkozást
hogy szabadon tudjak dolgozni úgymond az
én néy-öt órámban amikg a gyermekek
intézményesítve vannak hogy a
maradékidőmben a gyerekekkel tudjak
lenni ez nagyban ennek volt köszönhető
igen hogy meg megálltam ezen az
identitás ebben az identitásban mint
anya és azt tudom mondani hogy ennek az
időszakomnak ennek az
életszakaszomnak ennek a 10 évemnek ez a
prioritása hogy a gyerekeimnek most van
szükségük rám most kilenc éves a a
nagylányom és azt látom hogy a következő
már a minitinikor elkezdődött és azt
látom hogy ahogy kezd kiröppenni ahogy
kezdi már piciben elengedni a
kezemet meg tudom tenni mert közben
tudom hogy visszajön és amikor szüksége
van rám akkor akkor ott tudok lenni
számára ss nagyon szeretném hogyha majd
ezt meg tudom tartani a jövőben hanem ha
ha ha úgy adódik hogy hogy nem a nem a
pénzkeresés visz bele abba hogy több
órát kelljen dolgozzak hogy feladjam ezt
az
otthoni igen hát most különösen
különösen nagy szükség van rád és lehet
hogy majd tényleg pár év múlva amikor a
gyerekek elkezdenek saját életet élni
akkor már jobban belevetheted magad a
munkába ami amúgy is izgalmas tehát
felnőttnek lenni izgalmas és ezt meg is
kell mutassuk a gyerekeknek hogy érdemes
felnőttnek lenni mert izgalmas dolgokkal
foglalkoznak
el fog jönni ez az idő ez ezt amúgy azt
kiemeltük hogy mennyire nehéz volt az
eleje a házasságunknak és azt kiemelném
hogy tényleg én is azt érzem hogy akkor
volt egy váltás amikor felhívtál
telefonon hogy menjek haza
és ritkán történt meg vagy háromszor
történt meg talán azokban az években
hogy hogy alkalmaztad ezt az eszközt
hogy hogy hazamenjek de a legsötétebb
pillanataidban amikor találkoztunk akkor
vált reális igazából számomra is hogy
ennél lennebb már bizonyos szempontból
minthogyha nem lenne és mégis mégis
valamiért visszajövök és bennem ez volt
hogy nekem ez a feladatom hogy
visszajöjjek ez a feladatom hogy hogy ha
én maszkolin akarok lenni akkor én
visszajövök a családomhoz ha pedig tehát
vicces hogy az a férfi aki ott hagyja a
családját hogy tegyük fel egy más nőt
keressen az nem maszkulin az az az a
könnyebbik kutat választotta nem a
nehezebbik kutat és ez egy olyan szép
dinamika volt hogy akkor azt láttad hog
oké akkor akor akkor elkezdtél megbízni
bennem és utána persze egy
évek tehát évek kellettek ahhoz hogy ezt
a bizalmat még magasabbra emeljük de
valójában most is az van hogy én nem azt
érzem hogy hogy elkészült a házasságunk
habár nagyon izgalmas és én nagyon
élvezem hanem az van bennem wow vajon mi
lesz jövőre mi lesz öt év múlva vajon mi
lesz 10 év múlva hogyha ezt így
folytatjuk ennek mi a felső határa
úgyhog arra gondoltam hogy menjünk
tovább a következő témához ami a
szeretetről szól és és bizonyos
szempontból már elkezdtünk beszélgetni
erről de szeretném ugye a hallgatók
számára is feldobni hogy a másik ami
számunkra egy hihetetlen nagy váltást
hozott egy paradigmaváltást amikor
amikor rájöttünk arra pontosabban
először én jöttem rá arra hogy a
szeretet az nem érzelem hogy a szeretet
az a másik személy megismerése a másik
személy
szolgálata
nem ha ha valakinek mindenféle szép
dolgot mondok hogy én így szeretlek s
úgy szeretlek és mindenféle szp szép
dolgot érzek iránta viszont hogyha a
másik személy azt mondja hogy ne
haragudj de amióta én megismertelek
téged azóta az életem sokkal nehezebb
lett akkor én azt a másik személyt nem
szeretem bizonyos szempontból nem attól
függ hogy én mit érzek és mondok hanem
az hogy az a másik személy szeretve érzi
magát hogy kibontakozódik hogy olyan
leszem mint egy virág amelyik egyre
szebb és egyre egyre illatosabbá válik
és egyre egyre
vitálisabbá vagy pedig elhervad és
elfonjad és a feladat k az neked is és
nekem is hogy egymást megtanuljuk
egymást megtanuljuk jól szeretni és a a
az egyik ilyen tipikus példa az volt
hogy én a fejemben kialakítottam egy jó
pár stratégiát hogy hogyan foglak téged
jól szeretni azokba a nehéz időkbe az
elején például megint egy ilyen vicces
példa a nagyon nehéz volt az elválás
amikor reggelente én bementem dolgozni
és akkor megegyeztünk hogy akkor én
kilenc-re bemegyek dolgozni de én még
húztam egy kicsit az időt hogy lecsépjek
a munkaidőmből itt ott azért hogy hogy
minél többet legyek aak a családdal
úgyhogy emiatt így tötymörögtem hogy
kimentem és lassan húztam a cipőts még
lehúztam és visszamentem és és bennem az
volt a tévképzet hogy én ezzel jól
szeretlek téged megnyújtom az időt
ameddig még otthon vagyok és egyszer
kitörtél egy ilyen egy egy ilyen
egy egy ilyen egy valahogy ostoroztál
yet egy ilyen ostorcsapással hogy hogy
mikor mész már el inne meddig
tötymörögsz itt és akkor nagyon
megbántott engem de utólag értettem meg
hogy valójában számodra ez pont hogy
kivétel volt a bizalmi bankszám rosszul
szerettelek ezáltal mert mint
tötymöröktem te már azt mtál hogy ha már
így is úgy is el kell váljunk egymástól
akkor akkor mikor fog minél hamarabb ez
megtörténni htelenn érjen végett a
fájdalom igen menjél ki menj menj már ki
az ajtón ne mint hog cú és és emlékszem
hogy még volt egy hasonló pillanat
amikor amikor én megszerveztem a
napunkat és és valami vita volt és már
tényleg úgy voltam vele én már nem tudom
mit tudjak it találni tehát én a
családom mellett vagyok az egész
életemet ide szántam nincsen szabadidőm
nem járok semerre nem járok edzeni sem
de pedig nagyon hiányzott a konditerem
és és az az érzésem hogy lóg ki a
nyelvem és mégsem elég és akkor
emlékszem leültünk beszélgetni és
pontról pontra átbeszéltük a napunkat
hogy reggel hogy indul ezzel jól
szeretlek-e és rájöttünk arra hogy egy
csomó mindent teszek amivel nem csak
hogy nem szeretlek jól hanem pont hogy
rosszul szeretlek bosszantalak igen és
van egy jó pár dolog ami nekem ennyire
egyszerű lenne bossant és azzal jól
szeretnének és nekem eszembe se jut hát
nekem annyira pofon egyszerű nekem nem
is tűnik ez munkának úgyhogy úgyhogy
elkezdtük leírni ezeket elkezdtünk egy
konkrétan egy heti beosztást tervezni és
azt éreztem hogy nem hiszem el te is
felszabadultál én is felszabadultam
egymást jól tudjuk szeretni és hogy
mennyire egyszerű és mennyire frappáns
és felszabadító volt emlékszel-e ezekre
a a vitákra hát hogyne hát ezek
állandó mivel egy nőt meg megismerni nem
olyan mint egy festmény amit nézel utána
megtanulod ha sokat nézted és már a
végén minden ecsetvonás a a szemedbe ég
beleég az agyadba a teljes kép tehát egy
nő nem ilyen mert egy nem statikus nem
statikus és nem csak a havi ciklusra
gondolok ami a négy évszakot sűríti be
egy hónapba ennek minden hangulati
érzelmi
ingadozásával és fizikai
elváltozásaival hanem
önmagában a gyerekvállalás a várandóság
a szoptatás a szülés utáni a a a gyerek
leválása a női test változásai
hormonális tehát olyan szintű változás
ez hogy egyszer szeretem hogyha hozzám
érsz és simogatod a vállam két hónap
múlva meg már ki nem állhatom ne érj
hozzám de a hónapnak vannak szakai
amikor érj hozzám s vannak szakai amikor
ne érj hozzám és ez csak egy külső dolog
de ehhez még egy csomó minden kapcol
igen és nincs egy kézikönyv amit így
ideadsz és 340 oldalé kézik nincs egy
2000 oldalas kézikönyv amit ha elolvasol
akkor most már tudod és akkor azt úgy
csinálod ebben nekünk mint nők is kell
növekedjünk hogy
tanítgassunk pontosan jó tanár kell
legyen valaki ahhoz hogy megtanítsa a
másikat hogy jó másik pedig jó di hy
szeretni nekem nagyon sokat jelentett ez
az elv amit behoztál nagyon rosszul
esett eleinte hogy kijelentetted hogy
nem mondhatjuk egymásnak hogy szeretlek
de be kellett ismerjem azt hogy ez
ez egy jogos
feladat mert
például ha hozol egy
csokorvirágot akkor azt mondom hogy
szeretlek de ettől te nem érzed szeretve
magad hogy hoztál egy csokorvirágot
tehát mertogy éppen te tettél bele a
kapcsolatunkba mer igen mert nem
tudhatom hogy jól szeretlek vele tehát
hogy é biztos hogy örülök neki pontosan
tehát hogy ahhoz meg kell kérdezem most
jól szerettelek ezzel a csokorvirággal
nyilván jobb ha azt mondom hogy jól
szerettél vagy visszajelzek valahányszó
jól szeretsz mert akkor azt le tudod
írni a kézikönyvedbe hogy ezzel ilyen
helyzetbe jól szeretem üüm és akkor így
így a végül is ezt is csináltuk a
házasságunk elején hogy egymásnól
elkezdtünk így jegyzetelni és így
gondolkodni hogy hogyan lehet a másikat
jól szeretni
igen ez a ez ez a különbség a
jóáéségekig vezetett ez
ez a különbség a jóság és a szeretet
között hogy amikor jó vagyok akkor a
saját magam keretrendszeréből indulok ki
hogy azt adom a másik személynek amit én
gondolok hogy neki jó a szeretet pedig
az amikor megismerem a másikat és azt
adom ami számára jó és ez egy áldozattal
jár mert ki kell mozduljak az én
világomból é egy teljesen új világot ami
ami furcsa lehet időnként számunkra meg
kell ismerjünk és lehet hogy ott van a
rizikó hogy még változnunk is kell ahhoz
hogy a másikat jól szeressük
úgyhogy nagyon kényelmetlen valakit jól
szeretni ez tényleg egy szolgálat és és
ezt elkezdtük gyakorolni tehát ez ez
egyértelmű hogy hogy te is gyakorlod és
én is gyakorlom ezt és ez ez ennek nincs
felső határa ez a szép nincs felső
határa mennyire lehet jól szeretni a
másik személyt de ez a fajta i love
you barbis naplemés
rózsaszín felületes fajta szeretet ez ez
nem az a fajta amiről amúgy jézus is
beszél igen abszolút ez teljesen
biblikus tehát amit ír a szeretetről
hogy türelmes hogy jóságos ezek mind
akkor tudnak teljesülni ha azt tudod azt
a türelmet tudod adni a másiknak vagy
azt tudom adni neked amire neked
szükséged van tehát néha azzal szeretlek
jól ha hallgatok igen vagy várok egy
kicsit egy vitába hogy kell egy kicsit
várjak amíg te át tudod gondolni mert én
kész lennék azonnal megbeszélni de azzal
szeretlek jól ha adok neked egy 5-10
perces levegőt és végig tudod gondolni
és mikor visszajössz akkor meg tudjuk
beszélni és talán én is lenyugszom abba
az az időbe egy kicsit át tudom én is
jobban meg meg néha azzal hogy az egómat
lerombolod tehát ez egy fájdalmas dolog
amikor nekem támadsz
viszont az az igazság hogy sokszor jól
szerettél vele hogy hogy olyankor hívtad
fel a figyelmemet akármilyen módon hogy
hogy tegyük fel arrogáns vagyok
hogy hogy leromboltad bennem ezt az
arroganciát
a a szeretet az nem mindig kedves
mondjam úgy hogy a másik félné néha
fájdalmas inkább nem mindig konfliktus
kerülő nem nem mindig konfliktus kerü
hanem bele mer menni a megbeszélésbe és
a bizalmat szavaz a másiknak ez is egy
fontos szabály amit a házasságunk elején
szögeztünk le hogy nem nem egymás
ellenségei vagyunk és álljunk úgy hozzá
mintogyha mindig együtt állnánk egy
térfelen a konfliktus ellenébe
és talán amit még elmondanék itt a
szeretettel
kapcsolatban hogy a párkapcsolatnak a
szerepe lenne az ahol egy alap
megismerésre és volt nálunk is az ahol
egy alap megismerésre jutottunk tehát mi
azért kezdtünk úgy kezdtünk el
ismerkedni és együtt járni hogy annak a
célja a házasság volt el is döntöttünk
hogy de már az első randinkon
eldöntöttük ezt hogy azért ismerkedünk
és azt is h tiztaság maradunk hogy nem
nem fekszünk le egészen csak házasság
után esküvő után bocsánat
és amit nehéz volt megtartani nagyon
nehéz volt megtartani tehát ne ne tudjön
úgy a hallgatóknak hogy e ez olyan
könnyen j volt egy prű dolog
viszont meg kellett ismerjük egymást
tehát ez egy tanulós folyamat volt és
azt tudnám mondani hogy amit észrevettem
hogy a a párkapcsolat a házasság előtti
idő nem a szeretetről szól nem az a
lényege hogy szeresse egymást a két
ember mert az az az a biznis időszaka én
adom a pontosságomat és elvárom a
pontosságodat én adok türelmet te adj
nem tudom mit és mivel ez egy első
össze őrlődés összecsiszolódás
még nagyon durva és
abban az időszakban amíg ismeri meg a
két ember egymást el tudja dönteni hogy
ezekben az őszinte mert ugye egyszerre
biznisz de közben megismerés is és
elkezdik gyakorolni ezek amit megismerek
azt elkezdem gyakorolni hogy ezzel jól
szeretem-e és akkor ez ez vezet a tát az
alapvető szabályokat itt fektetjük le és
itt döntjük el hogy hogy tényleg
működhet-e ez mert ha az alapvető
szabályok meg annak akkor az egy falként
védi a a kapcsolatot és utána lehet
játszani akkor már bele lehet lépni a az
eskütételbe és az elköteleződésbe mert
már van egy
alapismeretem akkor már tud ő engem jól
szeretni hát nem úgy mint 10z év után
azért el kell mondjam hogy igen ez már
játék már izgalman már igen igen ez egy
mélység egy másik mélység ha tetszik ez
a podcast és szeretnél mélyebbre ásni az
alapelvek világában csatlakozz a
navigátor közösséghez a patreonon egy
olyan közösséget építünk ahol együtt
fedezzük fel az alapelveket és azok
gyakorlati alkalmazását az életünkben
ingyenes és exkluzív tartalmak mélyebb
elemzések és közösségi beszélgetések
várnak rád ha pedig értékesnek találod
ezeket az epizódokat és szeretnéd
támogatni a navigátor podcast
fenntartását ezt is megteheted a
patreonon a linket megtalálod a videó
leírásában arra gondoltam menjünk a
következő kérdésre de visszatérhetünk
majd így a a szeretet kérdésére mert
mert mert minden mindennel összefügg a
címe ennek a kártyának az hogy a
rendezettség és rendszerezettség vagy
rendezetlenség és rendezettség
ugyanis elvégeztünk egy ilyen
személyiségtesztet ez a neve hogy big
five és ez a személyiségteszt
öt különböző
dimenzióba jellemzi az embert ilyen
jellenvonásokat ír le és az egyik pont a
rendszerezettség hogy ki mennyire
rendszerezett amúgy megemlítem a többit
is mert lesz majd erről szó tehát itt
van a megértési szint vannak akik
magasabb a meg megért magasabbak a
megértésbe vannak akik alacsonyabbak a
megértésbe a neurotikusság hogy mennyire
vagyunk érzékenyek a negatív érzelmekre
a tudatosság hogy ki mennyire tudatos és
amúgy a tudatosságnak a két aldimenziója
a szorgalmasság és a rendezettség és az
ötödik dimenzió az a nyitottság hogy
mennyire nyitott valaki ennek is van két
aldimenziója az intellektuális
nyitottság és a művészi nyitottság na
most ez ezen a térképen ahol az öt fő
jellenvonás van és minden minden öt fő
jellenvonásnak van két aldimenziója ez
ez nagyon sokat segített hogy megértsük
egymást hogy hogy megértsem hogy te
milyen vagy és én milyen vagyok például
te sokkal rendszeretűbb vagy mint én
valamennyivel nem nem sok tehát nem nem
az van hogy én
én szeretem a rendetlenséget hanem
szeretem a rendet de meg kell te
tanuljam hogy hogyan csináljak rendet te
viszont nem csak hogy szereted hanem
szeretsz rendet is tenni és és a másik
az és tartani és rendet tartani úgyhogy
ez az elején rengeteg surlódáshoz
vezetett és az az igazság hogy it még
mindig van surlódásunk hogy hol hagyom a
a szennyest
például mert téged sokkal jobban zavar
valami ami nincs a helyén viszont rá
kellett jöjjek azt hogy ez a te
esztétikai érzéked mert tényleg
lakberendező és építészként egy
hihetetlen képességgel rendelkezel arra
hogy hogy hogy meglásd hogy mi a szép mi
az arányos mi a mi mi a a a a vonzó és a
lakásunkat tényleg egy gyönyörű szép
lakássá varázsoltad annak ellenére egy
kicsi 60 nmes lakásról van szó tényleg a
az utolsó négyzet centi is ki van
használva és szép ráadásul a szépség az
meg is védi a lakást tehát abban a
pillanatban mihelyt valamit behozunk a a
ha nem rakjuk el hanem csak úgy elkezden
gyűlni egyből rendetlenség érzetem lenne
tehát maga az hogy esztétikusan szépen
be van rendezve minden minden kicsi apró
dolog el is rontja ezt az esztétikát
tehát hogy emiatt közös munka az hogy
rendet rakjunk úgyhogy ez ez rengeteg
mindenre tanított engem viszont viszont
azt hiszem hogy íy általában a
házasságoknál ez egy probléma lehet ami
ez egy példa arra hogy mi az amit meg
kell oldani az öt jellenvonás közül és
akkor kicsit beszélgetnék arról hogy te
hogyan élted meg ezt a folyamatot vagy
hogyan éled meg ezt a folyamatot hogy én
valamennyivel rendezetlenebb vagyok mint
te és és az hogy a gyerekek azok a a
káoszt behozzák tehát hogy a a
gyerekeket meg kell tanítani hogyan
rendezik de az azért még nem működik
annyira nálunk valamennyire tudnak
segíteni például a házi munkába de azért
hagy kíánnivalót és tudom hogy sokat
bosszantod miatt magad viszont itt miket
találtunk ki ilyen stratégikus dologként
hogy hogy ez élhető
legyen van-e valami ami eszedbe jut
ezzel
kapcsolatban hát most csak annyi jut
eszembe
hogy tetszik hogyha rád szólok akkor
utána figyelsz tehát hogy mintha egy
emlékeztető kéne
két hónapos ilyen emlék rám szólsz akkor
egy két hónapig jó csinál rom romlik és
akkor megjavul igen próbálom a határokat
súrolni és hogyha nem szólsz rám azt
jelenti hogy nem láttad úgyhogy valóáb
mind l hát itt amit csináltunk az az
hogy rengeteg rendszert vezetünk be
kezdve attól hogy a gyerekek hova veszik
le a ruhájukat honnan veszik fel tehát
én a szekrényük el van rendezve
mindenkinek megvan m hol van és akkor
odaeszik helyre és onnan veszik ki meg a
rendszerhez hozzátart ik hogy ki miért
felel és mit csinál például az egyik
amit leveszel a vállamról és nem győzök
elég hálás lenni érte az a az a szennyes
logisztika tehát a ruhaogisztika hogy
hogyan kerül a tiszta ruha be a
szekrénybe az egy komplex rendszer és te
cserébe kértél pár dolgot például az
egyik az hogy legyen szárítógépot mert
ha nincs szárítógép ennek a praktikus
hozadéka vagyis a a a a hátulütője az az
hogy egyfolytában kiló kint lógnak a
valahol a ruhák és és kell kerülgetni
őket és nem eztéti dupán kell hozzájuk
nyúlni igen mert egyszer kiteríted és án
össze igen és és akkor úgy döntöttünk
hogy belefektetünk egy
szárítógépbe meg ez egy példa
gyakorlatilag de ehhez hasonló tudatos
rendszert kellett hozzunk jó párat ahhoz
hogy élhető legyen a a világunk igen
nyáron mikor kiköltözünk akkor a
gyerekek mosogatnak ami nagyon jót tesz
nekik igen felelősséget vállalnak és
igen e sikerélményt ad hogy ezt meg
tudják tenni igen amit rengeteget
kellett harcoljunk tehát nem nem nem
ment ez kön nem ment könnyen de most
hogy már be van járatva rendkívül nagy
segítség meg talán az is hozzájárul hogy
hát nem kimondatlanul mert azért
beszéltünk róla de a de de tudatosan
bele kellett egyeznünk abban hogy pénzt
fogsz költeni arra hogy a lakásunk
esztétikus legyen tehát én mint egy
férfi aki aki praktikus vagyok és és nem
szeretek tehát én sosem vennék egyik
kebanát az az igazság nem adni és amikor
te hazajössz és és azt mondod hogy 70
let költöttem egyik kebanánra akkor az
én feladatom az hogy behonjam a szem és
is elfordulja é és és utána azt olyan
dolgokat látsz meg amiket én én messze
elkerülnék tehát egy egy ilyen vásáron
amikor gyertyából virágcsokrot
készítenek számomra ez egy értelmetlen
pénzkidobás miért kell gyertyaviasból
rózsaalakú ik kebanánt csinálni de ott
van a fürdőnkben és meg kell valljam
hogy szép és és és az évek során
feltöltötte szépséggel a a lakásunkat
úgyhogy és nem csak ezt hanem a
keresztúri
házunkat is
úgyhogy úgyhogy én nagyon hálás vagyok
mert valójában ez az esztétika az
amelyik a legjobb énünket csalogatja elő
és rengeteg sikerélményt is ad tehát
amikor elkezdünk kétkezi munkát végezni
keresztőom fával dolgozni és megálmodhat
hogy ott legyen egy szekrény és ez így
nézzen ki és lerajzoltad én most már
évek óta megtanultam csendesen
alázatosan stábmunkát végezni melletted
és megcsinálni ezeket a dolgokat levágni
összeragasztani felszegelni felfúrni
mert a vége szép és és a végén jó jó
igen kellemes igenell úgyhogy úgyhogy ez
is hozzájárul ahhoz hogy hogy bár én
rendezetlenebb vagyok
általában lehet hogy ez pont amiatt van
mert egy intellektuális beállítottságú
vagyok és inkább inkább szeretem a a
rendet a az gondolatok között és a a
tisztaságot az elméleteim között mint
mint a fizikai rendet viszont ha kell
akkor meg vagyis tudom hogy meg kell
csinálni tehát nem az van hogy nagyon
szívesen mosolgatok hogy alig várom már
végre vasal hassak tényleg a másik a az
hogy kimondatlanul is azért én vasalok a
legtöbbet nyilván azért mert inkbe is
járok sokat de hogy ez is egy praktikus
valami volt hogy két hetente azért egy
másfél órát vasalok és hogy ha nem én
vasalok akkor te kéne vasalj viszont ha
te vasalsz akkor az egy akkora teher
lenne rajtad amit már nem szívesen
csinálnál úgyhogy néha megcsinálod
nyilván de azért azért ez így ilyen
ilyen rendek kialakultak igen tehát amit
így észrevettem az az hogy magadtól nem
érzel rá hogy mi a feladat
de hogyha elmondom hogy ezt vagy azt meg
kéne csinálni szemetet kivinni vasalni
akkor egy podcastet berakok a fülembes
akor te el vananulsz a világodba noise
cancering
és kizárva a világot igen megcsinálod a
feladatot
igen és akkor gyakorlatilag itt a másik
dimenziókról is egy pár szót kell majd
vagy beszéljünk például az egyik dolog
az az extroverzió hogy ki mennyire
introvertá és extrovertált az
extrovertált emberek azok akik a
közösséget szeretik akik szeretnek
láthatóvá válni akik szívesen
kezdeményeznek beszélgetnek
kollaborálnak és az introvertált
személyek azok akik szívesen dolgoznak
egyedül visszahúzódnak szeretik az
intimitást a csendet az egyedüllétet és
az évek során kiderült hogy én egy
introvertált személy vagyok ami nem nem
titok tehát a podcast ez nem egy
természetes állapota az én létezés n
nagyon kifáradok egy-egy ilyen
beszélgetés után és és szükségem van
utána a csendre hogy megpihenjek te
valamennyivel talán mint hogyha
extrovertáltabb lennél mint én de te is
szerintem az introvertált tartományba
kerültél lehet hogy pont az anyaság
miatt mert régebb azt mondtad hogy a
középiskolás éveidben inkább
extrovertáltnak érezted magad ez azért
fontos mert mert fontos az hogy tudjuk
hogy ki hol pihen meg tehát mi az igazi
pihenés és nem ha ha nem tudunk
megpihenni akkor folyamatosan fáradtak
vagyunk ha viszont meg tud pihenni akkor
akkor lehetőségünk van regenerálódni és
a házasságunkban e ez egy fontos eleme
hogy megtanuljuk azt hogy ki hogyan tud
megpihenni és akár
életszakaszokban is változhat ez hogy
hol tudunk megpihenni viszont ez is egy
folyamatos diskurzus köztünk hogy hogyan
segítsenek én téged hozzá ahhoz hogy
hogy pihenni tudj és fordítva hogy nekem
számomra mi az ami
pihenés valami jut-e ezzel kapcsolatban
eszedbe hát az hogy amikor látom hogy
hazajössz és olyan zavart vagy vagy
valami nagyon mozgat akkor inkább
elküldelek egyet sétálni és várok még
egy 10 percet vagy ugyanígy hogy akkor
megengedem hogy ledőj egyed mert 10 perc
alatt tudsz reszetálni
igen
újraindulsz akkor ez jót tesz a
kapcsolatunknak és a családi
életünknek nem tudom én hol tartok ezen
a tengelyen átalakulóban vagy nem tudom
valami furcsa torzió torzításba igen
tehát ez egy folyamat az hogy a gyerekek
elkezdtek iskolába járni és te újra
vissza kerültél a a a munkaerőpiacra ez
ez megint változtat egyet azt azt már
megfogalmaztuk hogy valami van a a a
kreatív és a kétkezi kreatív munka
között vag bocsánat a a munkával tehát h
valahol meg tudsz pihenni akkor amikor
festegetsz amikor valamit készítesz
valami szépet
csinálsz erre tudatosan kell építsünk
szerintem hogy hogy legyen időd amikor
festegetni tudsz most megfogalmaztuk azt
hogy például a színházba szeretnél menni
ez ez az egyik dolog ami még nem kerül
be az életünkbe de gondolkozok rajta
hogy hogyan tudjalak segíteni abba hogy
hogy te el tudj jutni színházba nyilván
a legjobb az lenne ha velem mehetnél
színházba de na ha hallgatók közül
valaki szívesen vállalna három gyermeket
akkor hogy hogy vigyázzon akkor
jelentkezzen na de
vicces viccről komolyra fordítva a szót
ez tényleg egy olyan időszak volt amikor
azért sok lemondás volt ebben hogy nem
tehettük meg azt amit szingli korunkban
megtehettünk hogy egy moziba elmenjünk
csak úgy más átalakult az hogy meg
kellett tanulniog hogy pihenünk és akkor
hogyan pihenünk például a randival az
egy az egy nagyon hatékony pihenés mind
a kettőnknek amikor minden héten
pénteken elmegyünk a nem meg nem
mondhatom kiog hova hogy kimondhatom-e
tehát ez egy podcast formátum elmegyünk
a gáfi csokizóba
és és akkor mindig ugyanazt rendeljük
szinte mindig ugyanodaülünk le szinte ez
számomra egy nagyon jó szimbóluma annak
a mozdulatlan mennyországnak amikor
elmegyünk randizni és valójában hétről
hétre nem változik se a az emberek is
ugyanazok ami változik az hogy mi
történt velünk azon a héten és akkor van
egy másfél óránk amit már megtanultunk
nagyon hatékonyan kihasználni nagyon
hatékonyan felhasználni és azt látom
hogy az a másfél óra alatt igazán
feltöltődünk a kapcsolatunk feltöltődik
és elkezdünk tudni beszélgetni és
vizionálni és örvendezni és ünnepelni
olyankor nem a logisztikáról beszél
lgetünk nem arról beszélgetünk hogy hogy
nem tudom sárának f füzet kell vagy vagy
vagy a többi gyereknek mi kell hanem
hanem arról beszélgetünk hogy valójában
mi is ai elhívásunk vajon mi is az ami
igazi örömet okoz vajon mi is az ami ami
hogy egymást jobban megismerjük a tehát
ez például egy pont ami feltölt minket
meg igazából nem csak ez a randi pontunk
van hanem azért igyekszünk még egy
alkalmat becsempészni egy reggeli
kávézás egy közös ebéd valamelyikor a
héten
úgyhogy ezek mind-mind olyan pontok amik
úgy érzem hogy feltöltenek mind a
kettőnket
igen jó
a következő kártya az a házi munkáról
szól de hát erről már beszélgettünk
úgyhogy én erre több időt most nem is
szentel végigvetted amit akartál a a a
pihenéssel kaps szségvonások vagy azt
igen hát beszélhetjük tovább akkor ilyen
szempontból a személyiség meg megnézem a
következő kártyán mit ír hátha pont
azzal
kapcsolatos erről is beszélgettünk
felolvasom a a magát a mondatot de erről
is beszélgettünk tartotok-e attól hogy a
másik személy elhagy ha őszinte leszek
vele van-e olyan körülmény amiben úgy
érzem elhagyhat tehát erről
beszélgettünk és ez egy nagyon-nagyon
fontos aspektusa a házasságunknak hogy
hogy hogy nincs olyan dolog amiért
egymást ott hagyjuk holtomiglan
holtodiglan ennek a a sötét nehéz
oldalával is együtt
a big five-ot tovább véve beszélgettünk
az extroverzióról beszéltünk a a
tudatosságról a rendezettségről van még
három másik dimenzió ami számomra nagyon
értékes volt most a neurotikusság volt
az a pont amikor rá kellett jöjjek arra
hogy ezt a ezt ezt a személyiségtesztet
érdemes komolyan venni amúgy ajánlom
majd mindenkinek a figyelmébe nézzetek
utána mert rengeteget rengeteget lehet
tanulni benne és hogy nem negatívak ezek
a tulajdonságok é nem egyik sem negatív
vagy pozitív mindegyik valamilyen tehát
és ez az egyik olyan skála ahol
homlokegyenes másak vagyunk a többiben
azért nagyjából valamilyen valamilyen
kapcsolatunk van például én is
introvertált vagyok valamennyire és te
is az vagy de például a a
neurotikusságban te egy magas
neurotikusságú személy vagy én egy
alacsony neurotikusságú személy 100ból
vannak még nyolcan akik neurotikusabbak
mint én igen tehát hogy hogy a a
hallgatóknak a a a kedvéért mondom el
hogy a neurotikusság azt jelenti hogy
valaki mennyire érzékeny a negatív
érzelmekre egy neurotikus személy
hajlamos pesszimistán látni a világot
hajlamos kevés rizikót vállalni hajlamos
a bolhából elefántot csinálni hajlamos
stresszelni a hajlamos a hisztériára
viszont a pozitív hozadéka a
neurotikusságnak az hogy hajlamos
meglátni a közelgő veszélyt a reális
veszélyt és ez egy nagyon fontos dolog
volt mert én viszont alacsony
neurotikusságú személy vagyok tehát hogy
a a az hogy a biznisvilágban tudok
működni ez ez ez annak is köszönhető
hogy merek rizikót vállalni nem érzem
annyira a veszélyt sokkal lazább vagyok
ilyen szempontból viszont a hátulütője
az hogy a veszélyt nehézebben is látom
meg és néha vannak valós veszélyek tehát
vannak olyan dolgok amik csendben
készülődnek és amiatt mert én nem vagyok
annyira érzékeny
térdre kényszeríthet és pontosan ez az
egyik amit megértettem popper által is
amúgy az az ő gondolata volt hogy az
igazán fontos dolgok csendben történnek
a betegség csendben alakul ki valakiel
egy párkapcsolat csembbe megy tönkre és
egy magas neurotikusság személy egyből
észreveszi tehát egy hét eltelik úgy
hogy kicsit távolodtunk egymástól és már
egyből jelzett hogy hogy itt baj van
vagy baj van a gyerekeknél baj van a az
a az a dinamika ami elindult az nem lesz
jó és én még nem fogalmam sincs nem én
én én én egy toleráns személy vagyok aki
a végtelenségig bírnám azt hogy valami
fertőződjön és viszont te nem te ilyen
szempontból nem vagy toleráns és nem
tolerálod a a negatív irányba való tehát
érződik a feszültség jön fel benned és
akkor h na jó akkor kezdjünk el
foglalkozni aé
hát hogy elkezdesz foglalkozni a
gyerekekkel és külön időt töltesz velük
igen ez ezeket mind te hoztad fel én én
magamtól nem feltétlenül töltöttem volna
t mostod őket sakozni egyesével igen
igen
úgyhogy úgyhogy a számomra így ebb a a
személyiség tesztbe ez egy ez egy
hihetetlen felébredés volt hogy az hogy
te neurotikus vagy ez nem rossz mert úgy
könnyű rásütni a bélyeget egy neurotikus
személyre hogy egyfolytában problémázik
ő a his
hisztériás személy aki aki folyamatosan
fölöslegesen jelez de ilyen szempontból
olyanok a a neurotikus személyek mint a
a kanárik a a szénbányába ugyanis azt
csinálták régebb hogy a hogy a
szénbányába ilyen kanárikat helyeztek el
és azok egyfolytában csipogtak viszont
amikor egy gáz szivárgás történik a
bányába ami amúgy megölné az embereket
először a kanárikat a akik felül vannak
azokat hallgattatja el és ilyen
szempontból amikor elhallgatnak a
kanárik akkor baj van úgyhogy a
neurotikus személyek azok akik jelzik
úgy mint a kanárik a bajt előre messze
messze csak nem elhallgatásal csak nem
elhallgatásal tehát pont fordítva monond
hogy én az én személyiségem az én
személyiségem nem elhallgat hanem
szirénázok hangosan sz igen tehát hogy
hogy esélyem sincs hogy hogy hogy
elkerüljem tehát annyira hangosan
szirénázó hogy muszáj felébredjek és ez
persze kellemetlen tehát aludni jó dolog
és én automatizálnám az életemet ha
tehetném mármint hogy hogy ez az én
természetes tendenciám hogy mindent
automatizálok és elalszok és és hogy
mert nem szeretek felébredni de viszont
te ébresztesz az ára ennek viszont az
hogy nagyon sokat stresszelsz néha
fölöslegesen is és akkor én én kell
bejöjjek hogy hogy mondjam úgy hogy
békét hozzak és é eloltod a tüzet igen
néha néha az az érzésem h olyan vagy
mint egy egy ilyen atom reaktor
amelyiket hogy magára hagynak é csakú
fokozódi fokozód és mindjárt jön a baj
és mindjárt felraobban minden és tényleg
és és akkor akkor akkor akkor be kell és
és ez egy gyönyörű szép dinamika nagyon
hálás tudok lenni ezért mert tényleg az
elmúlt években számtalan példa van hogy
te mentetted meg például a házasságunkat
vagy a kapcsolatokat vagy akár a a
cégnél is nálunk voltak olyan jelek
amiket te évekkel előtte már megláttál
csak én nem voltam h veszekedtünk ezek
miatt és és veszekedtünk ezek miatt mert
nem voltam hajlandó beismerni igen na de
hát ez van de most már hálás vagy és ez
jó és és jobban is látod most már a
jelzéseimre jobban figyel igen igen
megtanultam figyelni és nem és ezáltal
másnak a jelzéseire a cégnél nálunk is
vannak neurotikus személyek úgyhogy a
cégvezetőknek ajánlom a figyelmében hogy
figyeljetek azokra akik akik
neurotikusak mert a neurotikusak
előrejelzik a problémákat é van csendes
neurotikus is aki akkor nagyon hallgat
és akkor tudod hogy rá kell kérdezni
tehát nem úgy van hogy mondják az
emberek hogy ó hát az az ő felelőssége
és akkor hogyha gondja van akkor az az ő
felelőssége hogy kifejezze és elmondja
tehát hogyha egy cégvezető fejlődni akar
és fejleszteni akarja a vállalkozását
akkor meg kell kérdezze oda kell menjen
és megkérdezze hogy mit látsz hogy látod
hogy vagy hogy érzed magad igen és
ugyanez szerintem a a párkapcsolatban és
házasságban is hogy közös a felelősség
itt most már nincs nem lehet
szétválasztani fontos hogy mindig élő
legyen a kapcsolatunk ez egy nagyon
érdekes fordulópont volt a
házasságunkban mikor azt
mondtad én elkezdtem áthajolni egy ilyen
megengedőbe hogy na akkor engedjük meg
hogy akkor egy-két hét vagy egy-két nap
elmenjen ezzel a konfliktussal és aztán
hétvégén megbeszéljük de közben meg
nagyon rosszul éreztem magam és akkor
leültünk beszélgetni és elmondtad hogy
hát te úgy hiszed hogy ez lehetséges
láttál egyszer valahol egy házasságot
valahol messze amerikába
és ott lehetséges volt az hogy mindig
élő mindig rendben van mindig toppon
vannak egymással sose úgy van hogy na
majd azon a vakáción megoldjuk a
konfliktusokat és kibékülünk addig
valahogy elélünk egymás mellett és akkor
majd rendbe tesszük hanem állandóan élő
örökké szeretettel teljes
béke j béké hordozó kapcsolat és
azt ezt a reményt adta hogy hogy létezik
ilyen és utána elkezdtük megélni és
tényleg létezik és tényleg létezik
hogyha ha nem hallogatjuk s ha nem
teszünk úgy hogy nincsen bennem
konfliktus hogy na mindegy ezt még le
tudom nyelni és akkor aztán majd eljön
egy olyan dolog ami nekem tetszik s ott
megbeszéljük hanem gyere ma este
akármilyen kellemetlen akármilyen késő
van vagy akár most kérlek ma gyere haza
hogy beszéljük ezt meg mert ez fontos és
érzem hogy nem tudok más figyelni hogy
nem tudok igazán dolgozni nem tudom
igazán elvégezni a feladatomat mert
annyira bánt vagy zavar ez a dolog vagy
szükségem lenne egy néha van hogy
felhívlak csak azért hogy hogy elmondjam
hogy most volna néhány mondat amit ha
elmondanál olyan nagyon békét adna és
vagy tudod már hogy mit kell elmondanod
vagy elmondom hogy konkrétan mit kéne
elmondanod kicsit furán hangzik olyan
vezetettnek meg
megvezetettnek de de igazából őszintének
látom hogy hát igen mert mert az is egy
egyeség k nekem csak el mondani
beleférog nem hazudunk egymásnak igen de
én hogyha ezt hallom akkor az engem épít
pontosan pontosan igen hát
a az egyik amit élünk a házasságunkban
az hogy úgy nem fekszünk le hogy nem
békülünk ki tehát hogy
hogy persze volt rá alkalom hogy hogy
puffogtam és kimentem a a nappaliba s
akkor ott feküdtem le de egy óra múlva
úgy is megbeszéltük tehát hogy úgy nem
keltünk fel vagy nagyon-nagyon ritkán
történt meg az elmúlt 13 évben hogy
reggel felkeltünk és még a konfliktus
tartott de akkor az nap megbeszéltük
tehát olyan hogy egy hétig elhúzóott
vagy három napig olyan volt hogy nem
mentél el a munkába hogy tudjuk bes pers
persze olyan hogy inkább addig nem
mentem be dolgozni akármi vaná nagyon
sokat jelentett el kell mondjam nagyon
sokat jelentett és bizalomba is nagyon
sokat beletett de az az igazság meg is
tehettük tehát olyan a munkahelyünk vagy
olyan volt a munkahelyet hogy hajszál
hián de belefért valahogy meg lehetett
oldani igen de ez rosszabb mint a
betegség hogyha vita van köztünk tehát
hogy most ha beteg szabadnapot valaki
kivehet mert nem tud dolgozni akkor
bizonyos szempontból én motiváltnak
tartom hogy valaki ha nem rendezi a
kapcsolatait a feleségével akkor akkor
akkor az legyen a top prioritás tehát
amúgy se tudok bemenni én én dolgozni és
mint programozó gondolkozni a a nem
tudom hogy ha konfliktus van bennem
tehát hogy minden olyan értelmetlen nek
tűnik minden olyan tehát a házasságunk
mélyebb számomra az ident tehát úgy
képzelem el az identitásomat mint egy
ilyen létrát amelyik megy fel a
mennyországig és és egy sokkal alapabb
dolog a házasság számomra mint a munka
identitás szempontjából valahogy ha a
munka nem sikerül vagy nem van egy rossz
napom az az nem hat ki annyira a
házasságomra és nem kérdőjelezem meg
magam de ha a házasságomban baj van
akkor minden meg kérdőjelezek valahogy
úgy semminek sinincs értelme már ez egy
tényleg egy alap alapdlog és ilyenz
szempontból egy nagyon mély megélésem
volt nem tudom hogy emlékszel-e hogy
amikor körülbelül egy éve vagy kicsivel
több mint egy éve kolozsváron voltunk
volt egy álmom amikor azt álmodtam hogy
a hogy megcsaltál és utána pedig hidegen
közöny közönnyel beszéltél arról hogy
hogy ez hát igen ez megtörtént és azt a
fajta árulást azt a fajta mély mély
csalódottságot éreztem az álmomban hogy
ez ezt ezt ezt nem hiszem el hát e
ébredj fel tehát hogy meg álmoman
gondoltam hogy ébredj fel hogy hogy hogy
hogy ez amit csinálsz ez ez nem helyes
és amikor felkeltem azt kellett
realizáljam hogy
valójában benne van a top öt
legrémisztőbb áloman számomra amit egész
életemben álmodtam ugye 30 év során vagy
37 év során hogy hogy hogy csalódok ebbe
a házasságba hogy hogy ez az a fajta
mély árulás ami például a hűtlenséggel
jár ez
ez ez elképzelhetetlen számomra és ez
nyilván én nem is feltételezem ezt róla
é tudom hogy akkora bizalmi szint
köztünk hogy gyakorlatilag három
másodperc alatt látom rajtad hogyha
valami nem stimmel sokkal kisebb
dolgokat én is érzek rajtad és te is
rajtam viszont akkor tudatosult egy éve
bennem hogy valójában mennyire de
mennyire mélyen belészövődött az én
identitásomban az hogy mi házasok
vagyunk
úgyhogy igen ezzel nagyon mély dolgot
érintettél mert egyrészt
amikor házasságot kött két ember akkor
ha ahhoz hogy megengedje hogy ennyire
összeszövödjön az élete életük
megengedjék egymásnak vulnerábilisá kell
váljanak tehát meg kell engedjék meg
kell meg kell engedjék hogy a másik
meglássa a gyenge oldalát a bűnös
oldalát
a beengedje oda ahol ahol még koszos és
még nincs rend azokba az emlékekbe
azokba
a kapcsolatokba
ö múltban család családi szövődményekbe
be kell engedni a másikat és ott engedni
hogy ő is bontakozzon és igazából nekünk
ebben nagyon sokat segített a
lelkivezetőnk szóval 10 éve járunk és
igazából nagyon nagy érték minden
alkalom még ma is amikor valamit
helyreetesz a fejünkbe de ott is meg
kell engedjük hogy meglássa vez ez a
lelki vezető megláthat megláthassa a
gyengeségemet a a sebzettségemet és ez
borzasztóan idegesítő tehát ezt a gögös
hogy mondjam a büszkeségben nagyon
mélyen igen tipró dolog valakit oda
beengedni mer meg kell halljunk hogyha
valamire rájövünk meg kell halljunk
annak a dolognak és ez
nehéz és ugyanígy amit mond az hogy
ennyire kiszol bennem is megvolt ez a
kérdés hogy ennyire kiszolgáltatottnak
engedni magam
ennyire beledőlni hogy akkor te
megkeresed azt a pénzt te gondoskodni
fogsz rólam én nem ragaszkodok a
pénzkeresési forráshoz hogy teljesen
úgymond eltartott leszek mert a világ
annak titulálja a az asszonyt aki otthon
ül a gyerekekkel megengedem a
büszkeségemből azt hogy eltartott legyek
miközben elvégzem azt a láthatatlan
szolgálatot otthon ami ami nélkül minden
szétesne ami han nin csak a kor látszik
és igazából nincs értékelve mint most
visszajöttem építésznek mennyire pozitív
tapasztalat mennyi pozitív visszajelzést
kapok mind építész
és sokkal nagyobb a a
értékelése annak hogy néy-öt órában
akkora energiaforrás ez mint otthon az a
rengeteg legőrizett óra van néha egy-egy
köszönet és vannak pozitív
visszajelzések csak nagy non sokat kell
rájuk várni szóval ez egy
kiszolgáltatott
helyzet femininnek lenni anyának lenni
feleségnek lenni és tényleg tényleg kell
ez a bizalom hogy bele tud adni én én
azt mondom hogy hogy nem is lehet ezt
isten nélkül igazán
mélységeibe pont azért
mert azt kell tudjam mondani van egy
ilyen kérdés bennem hogy kiz áltatottá
engedem tenni magam de mi de mi van
hogyha elvesz ha ha valami történik
veled és kilépsz az életemből most most
nem a megcsalásra gondolok vagy nem arra
hogy direkt hanem egy külső tényező
elrak és
akkor én teljesen szétesek mert mindaz
amit felépítettünk együtt építettük
fel és az az érdekes hogy ahányszor ezt
imában feltettem ezt a kér ist tennek
mindig az a benyomásom volt hogy ez
rendben van hogy ez jó hogy ez békét adó
és hogy ez kedves neki és igazából a
szentírás is ezt támasztja elé hogy
elénk hogy ez a házasság az egy
olyan intézmény egy olyan találmány ami
istentől jön és neki kedves tehát kedves
neki hogy ennyire kiszolgáltassam magam
és ennyire belédőjek feladjam akár a
karrierem de akár lehet az anyaságot is
fel kell adnom szóval lehet hogy el a
gyerekekkel történik valami hogy az én
most az hogy három gyerekes családanya
vagyok ez most már a társadalomban egy
elfogadott elismert pozíció
viszont viszont mi van hogyha valami
történik a gyerekekkel és nem leszek ez
érted hogy mindvégig én azt gondolom ezt
ezt épésszel úgy lehet ha az ember egy
ilyen gondolkodó lény nem tudom
elkézelni isten nélkül tehát rá kell
hagyatkozni
rá meg kell bézni abban hogy ő megtart
hogy pótolja hogy felépít hogy az biztos
hogy olyan mint hogyha egy kötéltáncot
járnánk hogy mint hogyha ha ha egy ilyen
vékony vagy akár egy hegygerinc ez ami
eszembe jutt nagyon sokszor hogy egy
vékony hegygerincen megyünk keresztül
ahol le lehet csúszni nagyon gyönyörű
félelmetes borzasztóan izgalmas és
gyönyörű és esztétikus de és látod a
hófötte csúcsokat és látod hogy merre
haladsz előre és izgalmas az út viszont
ha lecsúszunk akkor mérre tudunk esni
tehát hogy tényleg kiszolgáltattuk
egymásnak a a az életünket bizonyos
szempontból a világ szempontjából te
jobban kiszolgáltattad az életedet nekem
én mondjam úgy hogy én meg tudnék élni
gazdasági szempontból tehát én is egy
csonka ember lennék hogyha most kiesnél
a a a az életemből úgyhogy de erre
hoztunk pár rendszert amúgy ezt így a
hallgatók kedvére mondnám egyrészt azt
hogy van egy írtunk búcsú leveleket a
legközelebbi embereknek hogy
felkészüljünk arra hogyha valami
történik velünk akkor legalább egy levél
marad utánunk előre felkés egy üzen egy
kedvesség egy valami igen
ezen kívül pedig egy
gazdasági stratégia is amit hátrahagytam
én hogy mi fog történni majd ilyen-olyan
pénzekkel nem mintogyha gazdagak lennénk
de de azért mégis az a káosz ami akkor
jön az az az nem egy jó pillanat arra
hogy most gazdasági intézkedéseket hoz
és a az építésziroda a mikado amit amit
te alapítottunk is bizonyos szempontból
egy ilyen biztonsági láb hogyha
valamiért szükség lenne arra hogy te
legyél a kenyérkereső akkor készen fog
állni majd a a követ akkor csak fel kell
növelni akkor a négy óra helyett nyolc
órát vagy többet fogsz úgyhogy úy ez is
egy egy tánc ez is egy eg egy közös
stratégiázás egy játékrésze egy egy
borzasztó életszerű játékrésze amelyik
egyszerre szép és egyszerre néha azon
gondolkozunk hogy te jó ég ez milyen
milyen rizikók vannak a háttérben hogy
nem is gondoljuk hogy igen meg
említetted a megcsalást is hogy persze
megígértem hogy nem csallak meg de én én
annyira
gyarlónak látom magam tehát látom a
gyónásaimba mikor leírom a bűneimet és
egy hónap múlva elmegyek szinte
ugyanazokat a bűnöket írom le tehát hogy
nem tudom van fejlődés persze fejlődők
de de attól a gyarlóságaim jönnek utánam
tehát azért az egy nagy ígéret hogy nem
csallak meg persze igyekszem és
megteszek mindent és stratégiát építek
és de hogy ez ez egy nehéz dolog tehát
ember vagyok a földön igen és és úgy
gondolom hogy ezzel hasonló helyzetben
vagy te is nem nem gondolok naivan arra
hogyha egy nő bejön az élet be akkor
azzal nem lehet valami kapcsolatod
inkább megijesztesz hogy akkor akarom
tudni hogy mennyire áll közel hozzád
vagy engem az vigasztal ebbe az egészben
h talán itt is egy védekező reakciónk
már volt hogy hogy figyeljünk erre hogy
engem az vigasztal ebben az egészben
hogy nem a derültékből a v
villámcsapásként jön a megcsalás hanem
valójában a személy elkezd játszani a
gondolattal elkezd fantáziálni róla
elképzeli hogy milyen lenne hogyha teeg
fel a kolléganőjével vagy a a ha
valakivel ez megtörténne és biztos volt
már egy megnemértés a házastárs résst
tehát ez ez egy egy ez egy folyamat é
amit gyakorlatilag amiatt mert
neurotikus hogy egyből elcsípsz tehát ha
ha az első nap hazamennék úgy hogy nem
tiszta a lelkiismeretem meglátnád hát
úgy gondolom de én tudom é én érzem
rajtad hogy nagyon érzékenyen figyelsz
és nem tudom de úgyse egy napi folyamat
ez tehát egy egy hat hónapos folyamatot
biztosan elkapná ha nem az első nap
kapod el az első héten elkapod vagy az
első hónapban elkapod de ö de kizárt
szerintem hogy ezt ezt ne kapd el igen
érintettük a pénzügyeket tehát erről már
beszéltünk ez lenne a következő kártya
hogy hogy javasoljuk a házaspároknak
hogy beszéljék át hogy ki a kenyérkereső
mit jelent ez pontosan és mit jelent az
hogy a másik személy kevesebbet keres e
kevesebb jogokat kevesebb
kevesebb felelősséget tehát mivel jár ez
pontosan úgyhogy ezt most külön nem
bontanám ki még talán a nyitottságról
beszélgetnék ez az ötödik dimenziója a
jellemnek tehát beszélgettünk eddig az
extroverzióról hogy ki mennyire ki hol
pihen meg érzelmileg mennyire
extrovertált vagy introvertált
beszéltünk a neurotikusságról a
rendezettségről a tudatosságról
beszéltünk a megértésről hogy ki az aki
megértőbb ki az aki kevésbé megértőbb és
a nyitottság ez egy nagyon érdekes dolog
mert itt is amúgy ketté válik mert van
egy művészi nyitottság és van egy
intellektuális nyitottság és én egy
magas intellektuális nyitottságú személy
vagyok tehát azt jelenti hogy szeretek
absztrakciók
dolgozni te pedig egy magas vagy
viszonylag magas művészi nyitottságú
személy vagy nekem is van egy egy egy
egy egy egy
eg egy nyitottságom a művészetek terén
viszont nem annyira mint neked ez azt
jelenti hogy amikor például az
építészetről beszélgetünk azért érdekel
hogy mit jelent pontosan a brutalizmus
például meg olyan izgalmasnak tartom de
hogy annyira hogy most elolvassak egy
könyvet azért már nem nem tartom
izgalmasnak te is meghallgatod az én
gondolataimat sőt a félkész gondolatokat
is meghallgatod mondjuk most már azért
chatgtp eléggé átvette ezt a szer igen
sokat sokat beszélek a chat gptihez
szánom bánom a
bűnöm viszont a gondolataimat először
főként te szoktad hallani még így is és
megtanultuk azt hogy te a félkész
gondolatokat is meg végighallgatod nem
gyilkolod le nem azt mondod hogy hát ez
még elég nyers vagy vagy mondjam úgy
hogy viszonylag kedvesen gyilkolod le
hogyhogy legyilkolod viszont ez e ez egy
nagyon fontos számomra tehát tudok
beszélni hozzád és egy-egy gondolatot el
tudok mondani és emiatt nagyon-nagyon
sokat fejlődött a családunk ilyen
gondolatok miatt másik oldalról teá
pedig behozod az életünkbe az esztétikát
behozod a művészeteket egy-egy amire nem
feltétlenül vannak szavaid de mégis
azért elkezded a a a nem tudom az
arányokat tanulmányozni a színeket
tanulmányozni és például az hogy a a a
az életemben az öltözködési stílus mint
be bejött mint mint egyáltalán hogy
foglalkozzak ezzel ez is neked
köszönhető hogy elkezdtem ék bejárni
hogy támogattad hogy pénzt szánjunk erre
én egy igénytelen környezetben nőttem
fel nem nagyon adtam soha a ruhára és és
és ezt tanultam meg hogy az öltözködés
maga az az nem egy fontos dolog sőt
talán negatív hogyha valaki nagyon
nagyon sokat ad pénzt például vagy időt
energiát arra hogy hogyan öltözködik e
ezt például te segítetted többek között
hogy hogy megértsem hogy hogy az
esztétikus öltözködés az itás része
tehát hogyha szépen felöltözünk nem
magunknak öltözünk fel elsősorban hanem
a magának a kon társadalomnak tehát
hogyha egy kimegyünk az ú az utcára vagy
vagy egy tárgyaláson részt veszünk akkor
azáltal üzenünk és reprezentálunk egy
szervezetet hogy hogyan öltözünk fel
úgyhogy ez is egy szép kéz a kézben
járása úgymond a a a különbségeinknek
hogy te miben különbözöl nem tökéletesen
hanem vannak vannak átfedések de azért
mégis dominánsan te a művészi nyitottság
fele
tendász és én pedig az intellektuális
nyitottság fele
igen ez is sokat segített mikor hoztad
volt azokat a gondolatokat
hogy hogy miből áll az emberi
személyiség ugye van a testi valóság a
szellemi valóság az intellektus és
melyik a negyedik spirituális spirit
igen az ezt mondtam intellektuális
érzelm érzelmi igen igen
és azért is segített mert mert
beállítottuk úgy az otthont töltött időt
tehát a a gyereknevelési időszakot ott
kezdtük el gyakorolni hogy minden kapjon
bennem enni most most így fogalmaznék
nagyon tát mind a négy mind a négy
dimenziót fejlődni tudj igen igen tehát
hogy ez az
intellektus nem tartottam magam
intellektuális személynek de azért mégis
elvégeztem egy egyetemet szóval szeretek
tanulni és hiány ott az a hogy csak
fizikailag kellettem vagy úgy érzelmileg
kellettem mint anya hiányzott a tanulás
mikor neki fogtam könyveket olvasni
regényeket
tankönyveket nekem nagyon sokat segített
és ezt mai napig is folytatom és még
mindig azt látom hog annyi mindent kell
megtanulni és elolvasni és felfejlődni
csak teljesen más az orientáltságunk
igen viszont egy jó lehetőség a kávézás
hogy van egy átfedés megosszuk ezeket
mert mert érdekelnek a ezek a dolgok
amikor például a személyiségtesztről
beszéltem a pszichológiáról a
filozófiáról beépítettünk amit csak
tudtunk igen igen igen tehát hogy van
van egy nyitottság érdekes számodra és
akkor érzem én azt például ez egy jó
mérce akkor érzem azt hogy egy gondolat
készen van amikor téged is lelkesít
amikor m például nagyon élvezem együtt
olvasni veled a dosttoeski könyveket
hogy egyszerre olvassuk például a
kirándulásokon mert olyan archetípikus
szálakat találsz meg a szereplők közti
kapcsolatban vagy mozzanatokban vagy
személyiség
vonásokban viselkedésekben úgy együtt
ahogy történik a dostoeski
könyvben ami amúgy egy ilyen nagyon
negatív és lehúzó
történetszáll lenne sokszor negatív
végződéssel vagy kifejlettel akkor is
olyan szép ahogy megtaláljuk benne a
tanulságokat le tudjuk vonni épít és
inspirál
úyhogy ezért is szeretek regényt olvasni
mer amikor elmesélem a regény neked úgy
sincs időd regényeket olvasni és lassan
olvasok és amikor elolvasok egy regényt
akkor utána amikor átbeszéljük akkor az
annyira inspiráló hogy hozzáteszed a a
az intellektuális részt az a
gondolataidat a
igen na nekem is nekem is én élvezem
hogy te élveztipikus szálakat meg amikor
a filmeket nézzük akkor átbeszéljük
ezeket a filmeket és és hogy mitől
működik a történet ez az ember hangosan
gondolkodik és mármint a legtöbb ember
nem nem tud magába gondolkozni és én is
így vagyok hogy szeretek beszélni és
beszélgetve gondolk az egész navigátor
podcast azért született meg hogy érdekes
emberekkel tudjak leülni és komplex
témákról beszélgetni miközben én jobban
megértem és remélhetőleg a ebbe a
gondolkodási folyamatba a hallgatók is
becsatlakoznak úgyhogy úgyhogy ezt
nagyon nagyon élveztem hogy a az hogy
hogy vagy élvezem folyamatosan hogy le
tudunk ülni és beszélgetni komplex témák
ról elmondod a te nézőpontodat és és már
különbözünk ilyen szempontból annyira
azért mégsem tehát hogy nem égés föld
hanem mondjam úgy hogy én magas vagyok
és te egy átlagos intellektuális
nyitottságú valaki vagy te magas vagy
művésziben és én pedig egy átlagos vagy
átlagon al igen tehát a kihívásokkal
szemben azért nem vagyok olyan nyitott
tát sokszor látom hogy mint a
rocksztárok a koncert végén úgy bedobják
magukat a tömegre és akkor a tömeg így
tovább adogatja őket és hogy úy volt
olyan hogy elképzeltem hogy én én be
merném-e dobni így magamat így a tömegre
igen szóval nem egy komfortos szituáció
és azt látom hogy te meg olyan szívesen
kéred is a jó istentől hogy na újabb
kihívást akkor erre az évre vagy hát
használj ha má élek it akkor jöhet és
készen állok és nem adot fel egy könnyen
én én én én sokkal hamarabb exitelek egy
egy súlyos nyomás stressz alól kérném
hogy akkor na most már kilépnék igen
közben így végignéztem az összes
kártyátü a a vita utáni kiengesztelődés
ja hát erről is beszéltünk eről is
beszéltünk igazából igazából
végigbeszéltünk most már vagy 12 kérdést
így összeevisszaog kal az összes kártyát
mer de de ezeket a kártyákat akkor
megosztjuk a hallgatókkal így összegezve
azt látom hogy azért ütünk le
beszélgetni mert egy csomó igazi valós
kincset megtaláltunk így a házasságunkb
és úton vagyunk valószínűnek tartom
hogyha ez 10 év m ismételnénk meg akkor
még hozzá tudnánk tenni vagy még
mélyebben értenénk ezeket a a a
kincseket most ennyire tudtuk
megfogalmazni viszont azt látom hogy
hogy igazán egy játékká vált a
házasságunk egy egy valós játékká ahol
szabályok vannak ahol be kell tartani a
szabályokat de ha betartjuk a
szabályokat akkor egy játékká válik egy
élvezetes kanandá min a kertel a a
kertfallal körülvett igen a fallal körül
fallal fallal körülvett kert ahol
bizonság van az örök játék folyik olyan
mint egy tánc mert a táncnak is vannak
szabályai mégis a tánclépés akkor az a
az a begyakorolt tánclépés sorozat mégis
egy idő után improvizációvá válik és és
nagyon élvezetes így improvizálni
például önmagában az hogy leülünk egy
podcastre beszélgetni ez nekem két
héttel ezelőtt elképzelhetetlen lett
volna azt hittem hogy hogy te soha nem
vállalkoznál erre viszont mégis mégis
úgy döntöttél hogy hogy amikor a
házasságról van szó hogy és szerintem
nagyon jól ment ez a beszélgetés
úgyhogy úgyhogy szerintem ezt meg fogjuk
osztani és
és kíváncsi vagyok majd hogy ez hogyan
fog lecsapó komfortos ez nem egy nekem
sem amúgy komfort szomra ez nem egy
komfortos felállás igen de hogy az hogy
bevállaltad ez is egy a táncnak egy
része a játéknak egy része és meglátjuk
majd mi fog történni tehát remélem hogy
hogy használható és értelmes volt a
beszélgetésünk
úgyhogy köszönöm szépen hogy itt voltál
le is járt nagyjából az a másfél óra
amit amit szerettem volna erre szánni a
kedves hallgatókat akkor megkérem
hogy jelezzetek vissza nekünk írjátok
meg kommentbe azt hogy mit gondoltok a
ezekről az elvekről amiket így
felsoroltunk hogyan jelenik meg esetleg
a ti életetekben ha mi már kimertünk a a
fényre jönni ezzel akkor bátorítok
mindenkit hogy bizonyos szempontból
tegye ugyanezt és egymással osszuk meg a
az elveket a gondolatokat a
tapasztalatainkat iratkozz fel a
csatornánkra és adjatok egy lájkot ezek
mindmind segítenek abban hogy minél
inkább terjedjen ez a videó ha
értékesnek látod akkor
akkor akkor ezekben tudtok segíteni
nekünk hogy még több hasonló tartalmat
tudjunk létrehozni köszönöm szépen hogy
itt voltál én is köszönöm ha tetszett ez
a műsor akkor iratkozz fel kérlek a
csatornánkra ezzel tudsz támogatni
minket köszönjük a vekker
kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomt kének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre